Arab League ministers met via videolink
to demand and into foreign military
intervention in Libya and they said
neighboring countries have an important
role to play in ending the crisis we are
followed with great concern and condemn
the internationalization of the Libya
crisis aggravated by the open
involvement of foreign militaries
repeated violations of the UN arms
embargo in all directions and the
systematic recruitment of mercenaries
and foreign fighters the UN recognized
the government in Libya had downgraded
its representation in the meetings
concerned that the Arab League which is
based in Cairo is a strongly influenced
by Egypt on Saturday Egypt's president
Abdel Fattah el-sisi
threatened what he called external
military missions across the border and
several other members who backed the
Arab League statement including the
United Arab Emirates Saudi Arabia Jordan
and Sudan are actively supporting the
war Lord Khalifa Haftar against the
government it's a position that has
infuriated the government in Tripoli
it's a real weaponization of the peace
process given only two weeks ago it was
a Sisi that offered a peace deal in
Cairo at the moment that Ali MacArthur's
forces were in retreat and this is
really a policy of preservation
after thwarting Hefner's efforts to
seize the capital turkish bagged Libyan
forces continue to advance east in
support of the UN recognized government
Egypt says the red line for its own
security assert down to jefra and the
airbase housing advances Russian
warplanes according to the US military
Russian pilots supporting Russian
mercenaries in support of after
forces loyal to the government of
national Accord are right now on the
outskirts of cert which is a gateway to
Libya's main oil fields in the east they
feel they have HAFTER on the run but
that's only been the case since turkey
fully committed its resources to the GNA
earlier in the year and Egypt has
watched the change in the balance of
power with increasing alarm mood abdul
wahid al jazeera Tripoli